this is something that's come up as I've
discussed the piece even with men where
it's like okay well women do want like
men who are sensitive and aware and you
know Etc et cetera and then the guys are
like do you really because it kind of
seems like women always date bad boys
and I don't actually think that that's
exactly true but there is something to
the Limit do as I say not as I do do as
I do not as I say yeah basically it's
funny there's a friend of mine who's a
writer uh for a conservative magazine
and I have like joked about this where
she's like you know I meet all these
liberal women who say that they want a
guy who like opens doors and like is
works out whatever it's like maybe you
need to start dating conservatives
that's a conservative that's what a
conservative is called yeah well you saw
an article when uh super viral a couple
of weeks ago which is like a liberal
girl realized that the only guys that
she found attractive had the opposite
set of political beliefs to the ones
that she did